find the slope of the line pictured on
the graph so the slope of a line
is defined to be rise over run
or you could also view it as change in y
change in
y
over change in x
over change in x and let me show you
what that means change in x so let's
start at some arbitrary point on this
line and they kind of they highlight
some of these points so let's start one
of these points right over here so if we
wanted to start one of these points and
let's say we want to change our x in the
positive direction so we want to go to
the right so let's say we want to go
from this point to this point over here
how much do we have to move in x so if
we want to move an x we have to go from
this point to this point we're going
from negative three
to zero so we're going from negative
three to
zero so our change in x
and this triangle that's delta that
means change in our change in x is equal
to three so our change in x over here is
equal to three so what was our change in
y when our change in x is equal to three
well over that same
when we moved from this point to this
point our x value changed by three but
what happened to our y value well our y
value went down it went from positive
three to positive two our y value went
down by one so our change in y
is equal to negative one so we rose
negative one we actually went down so
our rise is negative one
when our run when our change in x is
three so change in y over change in x is
negative one over three or we could say
that our slope
we could say that our slope is negative
one third let me scroll over a little
bit
it is negative 1 3. and i want to show
you that we can do this but any two
points on the line we could even go
further than three in the x direction so
let's let's go the other way let's start
at this point right over here and then
move backwards to this point over here
just so that we'll still get the same
result so to go from this point to that
point
what is our change in x so our change in
x is this right over here our change in
x is that distance right over there we
started at three and we went to negative
three we went back six over here our
change in x is equal to negative six
we're starting at this point now so over
here our change in x is negative six and
then when our change in x is negative
six when we start at this point and we
move six back what is our change of y to
get to that point
well our y value went from one that was
our y value at this point and then when
we go back to this point our y value is
three
so now our y value is three so what did
we do we moved up by two our change in y
is equal to two so over here our change
in y is equal to two slope is change in
y over change in x or
rise over run change in y is just rise
change in x is just run how much you're
moving in the horizontal direction so
change in so rise over run in this
example right over here is going to be
is going to be 2 over negative 6 which
is the same thing as
negative 1 3 and you could verify it for
yourself take any of these two points
start at one of these two points and
figure out what is what is the run to
get to the next point and then what is
the rise to get the next point and for
any line the slope won't change let me
do it again over here we had to move in
the positive three direction so that is
our
run
so this right here is positive three
that's our run but what's our rise well
we actually went down so we have a
negative rise our rise is negative one
so we have negative one as our rise we
went down and our run was positive three
so our slope here is negative one third